[Music]
in 2017 hulu released the handmaid's
tale a show about a near-future society
in which a totalitarian group has
overthrown the us government adapted
from the 1985 margaret atwood novel the
series became an instant sensation but
even die hard fans may not know the
whole story
series creator bruce miller is no
stranger to writing for television he's
worked on a slew of popular tv shows
such as er everwood and the 100 but the
handmaid's tale was the first show he
created miller had been imagining how to
adapt the story on screen long before he
was able to make it a reality in an
interview with the dream cage miller
explained that he was assigned to the
book in college for a class he said i
loved the story i was always a big fan
of books that built the post-apocalyptic
world after school i read it a couple of
times over the years margaret atwood was
really one of the people that taught me
how to write and how to think like a
writer as my career moved into tv i
thought oh this would make a great tv
show explaining that he was fascinated
by the thought of diving into all the
details in the book miller saw a larger
world ripe for exploration but more than
anything he was attracted to the
characters atwood had created he
explained it all goes back to the people
who live in this world and how they
survive and how they're trapped by their
own choices i wanted to tell the story
about how these people lived through the
experience and how they came out the
other side alive and with some of their
identities still intact that was the
thing i loved about the book realizing
by the end that offred has kept herself
alive
along with being adapted for the stage a
handful of times including at the
haymarket theater in the uk in 2002 the
handmaid's tale also has a film
adaptation the 1990 film was directed by
volker schlondorff and starred natasha
richardson as alfred whose real name is
kate in this version faye dunaway
co-starred as serena joy with robert
duvall as the commander and victoria
tennant as aunt lydia the film loosely
sticks to the events of the book though
the last act plays out a bit differently
much as it does in the first season of
the series but unlike the series the
film wasn't well received it has a 32
rating on rotten tomatoes while the 2017
series scored a 94 for its first season
in a retrospective look back at the film
around the time the hulu series debuted
the movie buff summed up the movie's
review saying schlondorf's treatment is
idly drab and antiseptic indifferent
almost as though he felt atwood's vision
was cinematic enough
the design team for the handmaid's tale
tv series doesn't let any space go to
waste making sure each room of the set
is ripe with deeper meaning and messages
some examples include the commander's
office which offred frequently visits in
season one it's filled with things that
are off limits to women like books art
and alcohol in a similar vein alfred's
bedroom is a reminder of a life that she
can't have
if we're caught reading
they'll cut off a finger
second offense just
the land
in a 2017 interview with architectural
digest production designer julie bergoff
explained some of the meanings behind
their set designs saying we put a desk
there but she can't write so it's almost
like a remnant a remembrance of oh i was
a writer an editor i can't even sit and
write anymore they don't want you to be
vain anymore so we basically put the
shape of a mirror on the wall to make it
feel like at one point there was a
mirror there
while margaret atwood's 1985 handmaid's
tale novel is a work of fiction many of
the horrific details of the book are
pulled from real-life examples of
authoritarian treatment toward women in
a 2017 interview with the guardian
atwood said when it first came out it
was viewed as being far-fetched however
when i wrote it i was making sure i
wasn't putting anything into it that
human beings had not already done
somewhere at some time stylist published
an article with real-life historical
terrors that atwood pulled from like the
enforced dress code the handmaids of
gilead are forced to wear stylist wrote
religious clothing can be and still is
forced upon women by authorities and
other more conservative communities the
amish for example insists that women
wear long dresses made of dark fabrics
and head coverings every single day
another example is the enforced
surrogacy for the sake of the most
privileged getting to raise children
stylists reported in australia as
recently as the 70s indigenous children
were lawfully stolen from their homes
and placed in religious institutions or
fostered out to white families from the
end of world war ii up until the late
70s similar programs were carried out in
the usa and canada when asked about
real-life forced pregnancy in an
interview on the view atwood said which
century would you like to visit which
country would you like to visit
which state in the united states would
you now like to visit
in the novel the handmaid's tale all
people of color have been forced out of
gilead leaving only white central
characters and there aren't any lgbtq
characters in that woods novel either
but this isn't the case in the
television series a change show creator
bruce miller found vital he told time in
2017 what's the difference between
making a tv show about racists and
making a racist tv show where you don't
hire any actors of color miller also
told the hollywood reporter
real diversity actually is
the way to actually use those experience
because i think when you have a singular
voice in the room it there's no one to
challenge right
but the ways in which the show deals
with race is one of the biggest
criticisms it faces in 2017 the guardian
pointed out that what the handmaids go
through is eerily similar to what black
women went through on a daily basis
during slavery yet that parallel is
ignored in the show the guardian
reported none of these details are the
inventions of atwood's imagination or
embellishments from miller's writer's
room this is what actually happened
during 245 years of slavery in the u.s
albeit to black women rather than white
ones vulture also addressed this issue
in 2017 writing the show doesn't end up
considering the racial dynamics of
june's family or what it means to be a
handmaid of color in reality though it's
more concerned with the interiority of
white women at the expense of people of
color who recognize that gilead isn't a
possible horrifying future but the
reality of what america has always been
elizabeth moss has garnered a ton of
attention for her stunning lead
performance as offred a role which
requires a lot of close-ups of her face
as she deals with hardship upon hardship
with each of the close-ups offred's
emotion whether it's sorrow rage or
rarely joy is crystal clear and what
becomes clearer to viewers with these
close-ups is alfred's lack of makeup
naturally a handmaid wouldn't be allowed
to wear it as vanity isn't an option for
them in the dystopian society a
character not wearing very much makeup
isn't new for film or television but
it's rare for an actor to not wear any
makeup at all minimal makeup is
typically applied on the actor for
filming purposes even if to give the
impression of no makeup but the
handmaid's tale uses a much more natural
approach and moss foregoes makeup for
most scenes if makeup is applied it's
typically to make the character of
offred known in her old life as june
look more tired moss told yahoo style in
2017 if you're not sleeping a lot
because you're working your butt off and
you get dark circles and bags under your
eyes the more you have the better you're
supposed to look stressed in fact one
night i got sleep i came in and my
makeup artist was like oh dear and was
disappointed that i didn't have the dark
circles under my eyes that we needed
the handmaid's tale is a great example
of how powerful voiceover can be when
used well june's voiceover gives the
audience an essential look into who she
is at her core rather than the identity
of offred that she's forced into as a
handmaid discussing his surprise over
how perfectly the voiceover worked for
the scenes bruce miller told vulture in
2017 we shot these bits of lizzy just
sitting in a room quietly going through
emotional phases and when i watched it
paired up with the voiceover it worked
perfectly and i said that's lucky except
it wasn't luck it turns out that moss
had memorized all of her voice over
dialogue so she could run it through her
head while filming the scenes to make
sure the narration would match the
setting take some
[Music]
i don't need
oranges i need to scream
but moss is a bit more modest about her
acting chops she told vulture it's a
part of the script why wouldn't i
memorize it how else am i supposed to
know what i'm thinking i'm sitting there
for 30 seconds i have to be thinking
about something i just thought that was
part of my job
upon its debut many people viewed the
handmaid's tale series as a response to
the 2016 election in which donald trump
was elected president trump has been
accused of sexual assault one of the
many horrors the handmaids must suffer
through the show touches on abortion and
other women's health issues which some
viewed as a direct criticism it's a
connection that can't be completely
ignored but it's also one that's mostly
not true the hollywood reporter pointed
out in 2017 that much of the first
season was completed before trump was
elected making it one of the most
unintentionally relevant shows in recent
years however when the cast and crew
returned for a second season the general
atmosphere was much different on set the
2016 election results couldn't be
ignored and headlines about the show
made the connection samira wiley who
plays june's close friend moira spoke
with vanity fair in 2017 about how the
election impacted everyone on set wiley
stated coming back to the show it was oh
my gosh we have an even bigger
responsibility now to have this show be
excellent have it have all the integrity
it should have
the handmaid's tale was an instant
success and with that came instant
recognition at the 2017 emmys the hulu
show swept the night with 13 nominations
the series won eight awards including
three acting categories directing
writing and production design the series
also won the coveted outstanding drama
series
with these wins the series became the
first show from a streaming service to
ever win the emmy for best drama series
with streaming services becoming more
prominent and continuing to produce
award-worthy content the handmaid's tale
could go down in the history books
backstage after the show's emmy wins
show creator bruce miller told deadline
the way that hulu handled our show they
were bold and behind us and really
committed to making something
interesting if the streaming services
continue to do that i don't see a limit
to how many emmys they can win
the first season of the handmaid's tale
covers all of the events of margaret
atwood's novel so the second season was
an unexpected continuation of the story
for fans and with season 5 on the way
bruce miller says he doesn't currently
have an end date in sight miller told
the hollywood reporter i certainly don't
have a number of seasons in mind it's
just that i'm finding more interesting
paths along the way and more interesting
things to do as we move towards more
fascinating parts of the story miller
continued by declaring that there was
another person vital in deciding how
many seasons the show would get he said
when i said that i'll do the show as
long as lizzie moss wants to do it that
is born of the pandemic and born of the
work she's done this year she deserves
to have me there writing for her as long
as she wants she earned that this year i
will write beautiful words for her to
say for as long as she wants to say them
it's clear miller is proud of the work
he's done with the handmaid's tale and
seems content on exploring the story for
as long as possible he told the dream
cage i've loved this story for 35 years
i thought it was amazing and i am lucky
and privileged to be part of it now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]